This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方真的不敢进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不代表你就必须这样做，收听“知难”
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建设恢复力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己从另一端走出。收听《2%》。即数字TWO percent，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
这是一个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次伪造这个特定的测试并在销售中，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）播客。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Spake），欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们的二十多岁意味着什么的播客。
psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, back for the first episode of 2026. That feels bizarre to say, 2026. Like the years really do start coming and they don't stop coming. But I have a good feeling about this year, like a really good feeling, not to jinx anything. I'm also very superstitious, but the energy I just feel for the next 12 months feels amazing and I'm hoping either you're feeling that as well or perhaps my unrealistic delusional enthusiasm is rubbing off on you. As some of my long-time listeners may know, especially if you have been here for maybe more than a year or two at the start of, you
心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听另一集，回到2026年的第一集。说出“2026年”感觉好奇怪。仿佛岁月真的开始飞逝，而且停不下来。但我对今年有一种很好的感觉，一种非常好的感觉，不是想诅咒什么。我也非常迷信，但我对未来12个月感受到的能量感觉太棒了，我希望要么你也有这种感觉，要么我那种不切实际、近乎妄想的热情正在感染你。正如我的一些老听友可能知道的，特别是如果你已经听了可能一年或两年以上，在刚开始的时候，你
every new year, I personally like to set a theme for myself for the 12 months ahead. And I like to share that theme with you guys. Obviously, I also set personal goals and I have personal ambitions for myself that I'm like privately working on. But my theme is like the overall tone I like to bring to every decision for this year, every crossroad, my daily choices, my daily behaviors. I use it as a guiding philosophy. And the reason I do this is actually based on this psychology paper. I read a few years back on what it means to live a good life. And what people who deem themselves as having a good life do or have or think about and what they also avoid.
每年新年，我个人都喜欢为自己接下来这12个月设定一个主题。而且我喜欢和你们分享这个主题。显然，我也设定了个人目标，我对私下里正在努力实现的个人雄心也有所规划。但我的主题就像是一种总体基调，我想把它带入今年每一个决定、每一个十字路口、我日常的选择、我日常的行为中。我把它用作指导哲学。而我这样做的原因，实际上是基于这篇心理学论文。几年前我读过一篇关于过上好生活意味着什么的论文。以及那些认为自己过着好生活的人会做什么、拥有什么、思考什么，以及他们也会避免什么。
And in this paper, it was published in 2021. They looked at over 200 people over an entire year. and essentially what they found was that people who articulated a grounding belief system and had a strong personal philosophy for their lives and for their year were more motivated, they were happier, they experienced greater psychological health, and they made more progress towards their goals compared to people who, you know, didn't have a guiding philosophy or just had goals by themselves. The reason why is because it didn't just improve their motivation, it improved autonomous, intrinsic motivation. This is the strongest motivational source and it comes from genuine enjoyment, fulfillment, personal value alignment, rather than external expectations, rather than a fear of punishment, a fear of rejection. we know that time and time again, people who pursue things because they genuinely set their soul on fire,
在这篇于2021年发表的论文中，他们在一整年的时间里观察了200多个人。基本上他们的发现是，那些阐明了扎根的信仰体系、为自己的生活和新年拥有强大个人哲学的人，比那些你知道的、没有指导哲学或只有单一目标的人，更有动力、更快乐、经历了更高的心理健康水平，并朝着他们的目标取得了更多的进展。原因在于，它不仅提高了他们的动机，还提高了自主的内在动机。这是最强大的动机源泉，它来自于真正的享受、成就感、个人价值观的一致性，而不是外部期望，而不是对惩罚的恐惧、对拒绝的恐惧。我们一次又一次地知道，那些追求事物是因为它们真正点燃了他们灵魂的人，
because it genuinely inspires them and they find a way to do it and make it fun, they are more likely to find success and more likely to feel successful. Having these higher order values they sometimes call them also helps with successful goal setting because you're basically not putting any filler items on your 2026 goal list. Everything comes from this theme, everything comes from the heart, everything comes from the core value and core guidelines that are driving you from this year. That is obviously a long tangent. Basically, it's just a way of saying that if you want to be successful,
因为这真正激发了他们灵感，他们找到了方法去做到这一点并让它变得有趣，他们更有可能找到成功，更有可能感到成功。拥有这些他们有时称之为更高阶的价值观，也有助于成功设定目标，因为你基本上没有在2026年的目标清单上添加任何填充项。一切都源于这个主题，一切都发自内心，一切都源于今年驱动你的核心价值观和核心准则。这显然是一个漫长的题外话。基本上，这只是一种表达方式，如果你想取得成功，
however success looks for you, but specifically if you want to be successful in your goals, having a theme first and foremost is important. Last year our theme was your year for trusting yourself, trusting your instincts, knowing what's right for you, what's wrong for you, trusting your ability to endure hard things. And this year is your year for doing less and achieving more. Think being picky about what you choose to take on. think making your time and your energy quite an expensive exclusive thing.
无论成功对你来说是什么样子，但特别如果你想在你的目标上取得成功，首先拥有一个主题是非常重要的。去年的主题是“信任自己的一年”，相信你的直觉，知道什么对你是对的，什么对你是错的，相信你忍受困难事情的能力。而今年是“做更少，成就更多”的一年。想象一下，对你选择承担的事情挑剔一点。想象一下，让你的时间和精力成为一件相当昂贵、具有排他性的事情。
Think really devoting yourself to one or two big ambitions or projects instead of feeling like you have to be a jack of all trades master of none. Think especially fighting the pressure to do everything, especially in your 20s and instead slowing down, being really intentional. and as a result, seeing greater results from your concentrated input, from your doing less to achieving more. So let me explain why I chose this theme this year because there were a few other contenders. I'll literally tell you what they were. I'll put up my notes up and I'll find out.
想象一下，真正致力于一两个伟大的雄心或项目，而不是觉得自己必须成为一个万金油却样样不精。想象一下，特别是去对抗做所有事情的压力，尤其是在你的二十多岁时，转而放慢脚步，真正做到有意识。因此，从你集中的投入中看到更好的结果，从你的少做多得中获得成果。所以让我解释一下为什么今年我选择了这个主题，因为还有其他几个候选。我甚至可以告诉你它们是什么。我会翻出我的笔记来看看。
Some themes I tossed up this year were your year for working in silence, your year for simple pleasure, your year for asking. for more, your year for taking your dream seriously, all worthwhile themes, by the way, and like feel free to steal them from me, but your year for doing less and achieving more just stood above the more because I think it was kind of a combination of them all as well, but also because I think it like reflects a deeper, broader revolution we're seeing in society of people saying, I don't want to feel like I have to do everything. I don't want my only value. to be productivity. I want to be deep, not vast. Last year I was vast, not deep. I did so much, and yes, outwardly that looks like success, but I really just left the year craving, like,
我今年考虑过的一些主题是：默默耕耘的一年、简单快乐的一年、勇敢索取更多的一年、认真对待梦想的一年。顺便说一句，这些都是很有价值的主题，大家可以随意拿去用，但“少做多得的一年”之所以脱颖而出，是因为我认为它也是所有这些主题的结合，而且我还认为它反映了我们在社会中看到的一种更深层、更广泛的革新，人们在说：我不想觉得自己必须做所有事情。我不想让我唯一的价值。就是生产力。我想做到深刻，而不是广博。去年我很广博，但不够深刻。我做了太多事，是的，从外表上看这就像是成功，但我离开这一年时，内心真正渴望的，
devotion to something, if that makes sense, you know, to revisit 2025 for a little moment. Like, that was probably the biggest year of my life. The gratitude for it is overwhelming, but I'm going to be honest, I think, you know, it really did take a toll on me. And I really just ended the year being like, I'm exhausted and the gratitude therefore is harder. You know, I published my book, Person and Progress, which please, by the way, go and buy the book. Then I went on my book tour. I went to Australia, went to the US. I met like over a thousand of you guys, the listeners, which was like probably the biggest highlight. You guys, side note, are just so smart. Like, every time, I meet a listener of the show or like you come up to me on the street. I'm being completely
是对某事的全身心投入，如果这说得通的话，你知道的，稍微回顾一下2025年。那可能是我生命中最重要的一年。对此的感激之情是无法言喻的，但说实话，我想，你知道的，它确实对我的身心造成了负担。我结束这一年时，真的觉得自己精疲力竭，因此感激之情也变得更难维持。你知道的，我出版了我的书《成长中的人》（Person and Progress），顺便说一句，请大家去买这本书。然后我去了我的图书巡回签售会。我去了澳大利亚，去了美国。我见到了大约一千多位你们这些听众，这大概是我最大的亮点。顺便说一句，你们这些听众真的太聪明了。真的，每一次，当我遇到节目的听众，或者你在街上偶遇我。我是认真的。
serious. Every single person I meet is like the coolest person I've ever met. Like just so smart, so wise, so interesting. So that was a big highlight. I also started the YouTube channel for the podcast. I hired the first like ongoing team members for the podcast. I ran a half marathon, which like wasn't on the bucket list. I don't know how that happened. I adopted my dog. I bought an apartment. I moved countries. Like that's a lot of stuff. And it's a lot of stuff. And it's, all really good stuff. You know, I live in London now. Like, that's, that still hasn't like fully processed for me.
我遇到的每一个人都像是我见过的最酷的人。简直太聪明、太睿智、太有趣了。所以那是一个很大的亮点。我还为播客开设了YouTube频道。我为播客雇用了第一批长期团队成员。我跑了半程马拉松，这甚至不在我的愿望清单上。我不知道那是怎么发生的。我领养了我的狗。我买了一套公寓。我搬到了不同的国家。这真的是很多事情。而且很多事情。而且，全都是非常好的事。你知道的，我现在住在伦敦。这，这对我来说还没完全消化。
And I think some things just kind of slipped through the cracks. I also started my other podcast mantra, which I guess I can kind of break the news here, like won't be returning for a second season. And that's sad to say because it was something I was really passionate about. And I really felt like it brought out a different. of me, but I was in the doing more, achieving more phase. And I think, again, some things fell through the cracks and, like, to be honest, I just didn't have time for that project and I just kind of stretched myself too thin. And I wanted to have everything that I wanted right now,
而且我认为有些事情确实从缝隙中溜走了。我还启动了我的另一个播客《咒语》（Mantra），我想我在这里可以算是爆料了，它将不会回归第二季。说实话这让我很难过，因为这是我真正充满激情的事情。我真的觉得它展现了我不同的一面。但当时我正处于“做更多、成就更多”的阶段。我想，同样地，有些事情被忽视了，老实说，我只是没有时间去处理那个项目，我把自己摊得太薄了。我想把我想要的一切都立刻拥有，
not realizing that, like, by rushing through it, there wasn't as much care and there wasn't as much, like, craft and devotion that is really important to me and is, what I give and try to give to everything. And I think that, you know, so that decision, that outcome of like not doing mantra for a second year has really contributed to this theme. You know, you may hear this laundry list of things and be like, damn, like, what a productive year, Gemma had. Like, that's a really successful year.
却没有意识到，通过匆忙行事，其中没有投入足够的关怀，也没有倾注那种对我很重要、并且是我给予以及努力给予一切的精湛手艺与全心奉献。而且我认为，你知道的，所以那个决定，那个不再做第二季《咒语》的结果，确实促成了这个主题。你知道的，你可能会听到这一长串的事情，然后觉得：天哪，杰玛这一年多产啊。这真的是非常成功的一年。
And it obviously was, but I'm also very exhausted. And I think I've fallen out of love with what I'm doing, which I never want to have happened. because having passion and purpose for my work is probably like one of my core values. Doing more, you know, it's sexy and it looks good and it gets results and it gets praise and it gets you pats on the back. And if you're people please you, you're a perfectionist, you're someone who always wanted academic accomplishment and achievement. Like if you're someone like me, that feels great.
这显然是事实，但我也非常疲惫。而且我觉得我已经对我在做的事情失去了热情，这是我绝对不希望发生的。因为对我的工作保持激情和目标感大概是我最核心的价值观之一。做更多，你知道的，它很吸引人，看起来很好，能取得成果，能得到赞扬，能为你赢得拍背称赞。如果你是个讨好型人格，如果你是个完美主义者，如果你是一个总是渴望学术成就和成就的人。如果你是像我这样的人，那感觉太棒了。
But when you choose to do less and to be selective, I do believe you achieve more not in quantity but quality, which personally is what I want. Really what it comes down to, what this theme is coming down to is alignment over exhaustion, intentionality over intensity, what we do for appearances versus what we do for deep values and deep desire. The way I've been kind of thinking or imagining this approach is imagining approaching my goals like I'm a student. And to be a student, to be a goal setter, like there is,
但当你选择少做一点并有所选择时，我相信你取得的成就更多——不是在数量上，而是在质量上，这正是我个人想要的。实际上归根结底，这个主题的核心是：对齐重于精疲力竭，刻意重于强度，我们为外表而做的事与我们为深层价值观和深层渴望而做的事之间的较量。我一直在思考或想象这种方法的方式是：想象着像一个学生一样去对待我的目标。作为一个学生，作为一个设定目标的人，其实有，
kind of two kinds of approaches. The first is when you want to know a little bit about everything. You want to be vast and have all this knowledge. So you kind of move between this and that. And of knowledge is valuable just for knowledge's sake. But the second kind of type of student and type of goal setter looks more for depth and is basically choosing to special. right? The first, yes, you come away with a lot, but you don't have that same deepness to things. I want to treat the few selective things I choose to focus on next year, almost like a PhD. You've become an expert in your goals. You uncover deeper parts of something. And again, that word we keep coming back to devotion. You devote time and energy.
大致有两种方法。第一种是当你什么都想了解一点。你想要见识广博并拥有所有这些知识。所以你在各种事物之间切换。知识本身就是有价值的，仅仅为了知识而言。但第二种类型的学生和目标设定者更追求深度，基本上选择成为专家。对吧？第一种，是的，你学到了很多，但你对事物的理解没有那么深刻。我想把明年我选择关注的少数几个精选事物，几乎当作博士学位来对待。你要成为你目标领域的专家。你要探索某事更深层次的部分。再说一次，我们不断回到的那个词——奉献。你投入时间和精力。
And I think that represents your love and your care and giving that to a few things, or maybe one big thing you really want to do well is, I guess, more meaningful to me at the moment. Now, obviously in classic psychology of your 20 style, is there evidence for this? Like, there has to be evidence that this philosophy and this theme actually works. Do people who do less achieve more? It sounds really counterintuitive, but honestly, the answer is absolutely yes. Some of the most successful people in the world live and work exclusively by this principle of doing less to achieve more.
而且我认为这代表了你的爱与关怀，把它倾注在少数事情上，或者也许是你真正想做好的某一件大事上，对目前的我来说更有意义。现在，显然带着典型的“二十多岁心理学”风格，这有依据吗？这背后一定有证据证明这种哲学和主题确实有效。做少的人真的能成就更多吗？这听说起来非常违反直觉，但老实说，答案绝对是肯定的。世界上一些最成功的人完全依照“少做以成就更多”的原则生活和工作。
Stephen King, for example, only writes for like four hours a day. Einstein, you know, he like frequently took naps on a bigger scale. Take, for example, Warren Buffet. You know, he's just casually, one of the richest people in the world. And not that wealth is like necessarily
例如，斯蒂芬·金（Stephen King）每天只写作大约四个小时。爱因斯坦，你知道的，他经常打盹。从更大的规模来看。以沃伦·巴菲特（Warren Buffet）为例。你知道的，他轻轻松松就是世界上最富有的人之一。并不是说财富必然是，
the greatest indicator of all of life's successes, but for the sake of this, let's say it is. And the advice he gives to people is to make, a list of the top 20 things you really want to do or really want to achieve and then draw a line below number five. After that, ignore all the other items on the list until those first five have been achieved. That is how he says he has become the success that he is, doing less, achieving more. This is similar to the professor and researcher Angela Duckworth's idea of the pyramid of goals. or goal hierarchies,
生活中所有成功的最伟大指标，但为了这次讨论，我们就当它是吧。他给人们的建议是：列出你真正想做或真正想实现的20件事的清单，然后在第5项下面画一条线。在那之后，忽略清单上的所有其他前5项实现之前，不要管其他项目。这就是他成为今天这样的成功人士的方法——少做，多成就。这类似于教授兼研究员安吉拉·达克沃斯（Angela Duckworth）的目标金字塔或目标层级的概念，
whereby she recommends that people identify their pinnacle goal, something that's like become a GP, write a book, get an Olympic medal, and then ensure that their smaller goals contribute to this larger one rather than setting aside the pinnacle goal and just creating random goals and expecting the larger one to come true or focusing on a million disparate ones and then thinking that that's going to create your dream life. She basically says that when you're in alignment, your main purpose and
她建议人们确定他们的巅峰目标，比如成为全科医生、写一本书、赢得奥运奖牌，然后确保他们的小目标有助于实现这个更大的目标，而不是把巅峰目标抛在一边，只是凭空创造随机的目标，还指望更大的目标能实现，或者把精力分散在成百万个不同的目标上，然后认为这就能创造出你的梦想生活。她基本上说过，当你处于对齐状态时，你的主要目的和
ambition, even if that's just for the year, you know, tends to influence all other things and make stuff happen. And she does also talk about how, you know, sometimes that can feel a little bit limiting. Like the pinnacle goal idea can feel limiting, especially when we're in our 20s. You know, there is a lot we want to do and a lot we want to achieve and we have a lot of energy for our goals. But having a specific goal at any one time, I think will help you get to the place of achieving it faster. It will also help you eliminate that goal if it's not the right one for you.
雄心，即使这只是针对这一年，也往往会影响所有其他事情并使事情发生。她也确实谈到过，有时候这可能会让人感觉有点局限。就像巅峰目标的概念可能会让人觉得受限制，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候。你知道的，有很多事我们想做，有很多成就我们想达成，我们对目标有着满满的精力。但在任何特定时间拥有一个具体的目标，我认为会帮助你更快地到达实现它的地方。它还会帮助你排除那个目标，如果它不适合你的话。
Being devoted to something really deeply really helps you figure out whether it's the thing you want to be devoted to for the rest of your life. You know, for me, having one pinnacle goal for this year, especially as a 20-something-year-old, yes, like initially it felt uncomfortable. But I also realized that, you know, the cognitive load of trying to do a million things and not being able to achieve any of them is far worse than feeling limited by a deliberate choice. I feel like last year I was more limited by. having a million choices, then I do now feeling limited by having just one or two.
全身心地投入到某件事中，真的有助于弄清楚这是否是你余生都想全身心投入的事。你知道的，对我来说，今年有一个巅峰目标，特别是作为一个二十几岁的人，是的，一开始感觉很不舒服。但我也意识到，尝试做一百万件事情却一件也做不到的认知负担，远远比因刻意选择而感到受限制要糟糕得多。我觉得去年我受到拥有无数选择的限制，多于我现在感觉因只有一两个选择而受到的限制。
Really, the success of this comes down to just a few psychological principles. Number one being cognitive load theory. You know, our minds have limited available resources. It's why you can't, you know, really multitask or more than like maybe three things at a time and having too many priorities or too many goals does the same thing and often means that you're going to do all of them worse and not really achieve any of them. And it's similar to this idea of scattered versus focused effort. Scattered effort looks busy because you're freaking running around everywhere and it feels productive
实际上，成功的关键归结为几个心理学原理。第一点是认知负荷理论。你知道的，我们的头脑有着有限的可用资源。这就是为什么你无法真正地进行多任务处理，或者一次处理超过大约三件事情的原因，拥有太多的优先事项或太多的目标也会产生同样的效果，这通常意味着你会把所有事情都做得更糟，而真正什么也实现不了。这类似于分散精力与专注精力的想法。分散精力看起来很忙碌，因为你他妈的到处乱跑，这感觉很有生产力，
and it gives us the comforting illusion that we are on top of things because we are seemingly moving, acting, and we confuse that with being productive when a lot of it is just busy work. But cognitively, you know, it's one of the least efficient ways to work. Every time you switch between goals, tasks, context, your brain does pay a cost. It pays a tax. And that tax is called attention residue.
并且它给我们一种安慰的错觉，让我们觉得一切尽在掌握，因为我们似乎在移动、在行动，而我们把这与高效率混为一谈，但实际上很多都只是瞎忙。但在认知上，你知道的，这是最高效的工作方式之一。每次你在目标、任务、上下文之间切换时，你的大脑都要付出代价。它要付出一笔税。而这笔税被称为“注意力残留”。
When you have a million goals for your year, when you're trying to do everything all the time, moving between those goals, moving between those activities, a portion of your focus will always stay stuck on the previous task, meaning you are never fully present in the next one. In contrast, focused effort comes from being selective. And again, it means we are often going to experience deeper work, deeper curiosity and deeper joy in the thing that we're doing. So that's basically my argument for this year's theme of doing less and achieving more. Not only is it more enjoyable,
当你的一年有成百万个目标时，当你试图随时做所有事情，在这些目标之间切换，在这些活动之间切换时，你的一部分注意力将永远卡在上一项任务上，这意味着你永远无法完全专注于下一项任务。相比之下，专注的努力来自于有所选择。而且，这意味着我们将经常在正在做的事情中体验到更深的工作、更深的好奇心和更深的喜悦。所以这基本上是我对今年“少做多得”主题的论点。不仅更加愉快，
it also seems to be a much more successful approach to life, even if counterintuitively doing more we would think might get us to places faster. It seems that the evidence doesn't say that. So with that being our 2026 theme, let's talk about how we are going to implement it and how it should impact your decision making and how you plan for this year ahead. Stay with us. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers,
它似乎也是一种更成功的生活方式，尽管直觉上我们会认为做更多可能会让我们更快地到达目的地。然而证据似乎并非如此。因此，既然这是我们2026年的主题，让我们来谈谈我们将如何落实它，以及它将如何影响你的决策以及你如何规划未来的这一年。请继续收听。短暂停留后，我们马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建设恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员对话，
and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
以及其他健康与健身专家等，看透那些统治着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己从另一端走出。收听《2%》。即TWO percent，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends, I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金规则。规则一，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。你在玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说相信你的女朋友们，我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，才不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么狗屁关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作客的节目，滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，1984年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克毒品。我随时都可以聊快克毒品，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论快克毒品的第二集。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）。欢迎来到我的新播客《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们，其实已经拥有了这样东西。而我们却还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在世的好人很重要吗？你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能成为一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and personal. on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），我们将就疗愈、成长、父道、压力和个人展开真正的对话。在我的新播客《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way）中。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way）并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。这就开始了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你曾两次伪造这个特定的测试并在某人身上，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯平（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。所以大多数年份开始时，我通常会写下一大串我想要完成的事情，从小的、中等的到大事。而且我总是，我不知道我有没有说过这个，但我总是会写下一件，
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So at the start of most years, I typically write down this major list of things that I want to accomplish from littles to mediums to big things. I also always, I don't know if I've talked about this, but I always put something like really unrealistic.
非常不切实际的疯狂事情在清单上，纯粹为了好玩，只是因为我觉得，太好了，让我们保持富有创意的梦想之火源源不断地燃烧吧。比如去年我想我写了：在我的目标清单上写一个电影剧本，这，是的，用“不切实际”来形容大概是低估了。这根本不可能发生。去年，我其实制作了一张目标宾果卡（goal bingo card），上面有12个格子，贴在我的冰箱上，是我想要达成的目标。通过在上面放那么多事情，
and like crazy on the list just for fun, just because I'm like, yeah, let's keep the creative dreamlight juices flowing. Like last year I think I wrote, write a movie script on my goal list, which, yeah, unrealistic is probably underselling it. Like that wasn't going to happen. Last year, I actually made a goal bingo card, which was like 12 squares that I had on my fridge that I wanted to achieve. and by putting so many things on there,
就像这是一个有趣的活动，但我认为我某种程度上承认了：这些我不可能全部做到。其中一些从一开始就会被砍掉。其中一些将无法完成。这很违反直觉，对吧？你为什么要设定目标？为什么要设定任何你基本上知道自己不会去遵守的目标？
like it was a fun activity, but I think I kind of acknowledged, I'm not going to do all of these. Some of them are going to get cut from the get-go. Some of them aren't going to get done. And that's counterintuitive, right? Why do you set a goal? Why set any goal you basically know you're not going to keep?
仅仅为了设定它，并认为它可能会偶然发生？这基本上是在向你自己和你的信念系统发出信号，嘿，你其实不必坚持到底。你不需要坚持完成其中任何一些目标，所以为什么还要坚持任何一个呢？它基本上从一开始就告诉你，这些都是可选的。
Just for the sake of setting it and thinking it may accidentally happen? It's basically signaling, I guess, to yourself and to your self-belief systems, hey, you don't really have to follow through. You don't have to follow through with some of these, so why follow through with any of them? It basically says, from the get-go, these are optional.
所以相反，让我们借鉴沃伦·巴菲特的例子，写下15件你明年真正理想中想要完成的事情，不要在5个下面划线，让我们划线3个：两个主要目标，一个备用目标。一个备用目标，以防你运气爆棚，在年底前就完成了那两个目标。这可以阻止你纯粹为了抚慰自己的焦虑而设定目标——焦虑于你做得不够，或者焦虑于你应该做别人在做的事。
So instead, let's take a page from Warren Buffett's example, write down the 15 things you really ideally would want to accomplish next year, and instead of underlying five, let's underline three, two main goals, one reserve goal. One reserve goal for if you get really lucky and you accomplish those two things before the end of the year. This stops you from setting goals purely to soothe your anxiety that you're not doing enough or that you should be doing what others are doing.
它还可以防止目标冲突。太多的目标会争夺你的注意力，这意味着你永远无法将全部精力投入到任何一个目标上。我认为一开始会觉得不舒服，因为你没有这种承诺的安全毯给自己，让你感觉自己好像在做些什么，尽管实际上并没有。但归根结底，在年终时，你会发现这是正确的选择——现在限制自己，是为了在未来获得更多。或者，我将给你另一种方法。
It also prevents goal conflict. Too many goals compete for your attention, meaning that you can never give any of them all of it. I think it will feel uncomfortable at first because you don't have this security blanket of promises to yourself that feel like you're doing something, even though you're not. But at the end of the day, at the end of the year, I think that you'll see that this is the right choice to limit yourself now to get more in the future. Alternatively, I'm going to give you a different method.
如果这个方法不适合你，我以前也推荐过这种方法。如果每年只设定一两个目标的设定方式很难，那就把你的2026年分成三个季度（赛季）。因此，每四个月，也就是每个季度，你都有一个独立的主题、独立的目标或独立的领域，你可以用集中的精力全力以赴。比如第一季，那是什么？比如1月到april，也就是健身。那是重点，那是你的主题。那是那个季度的主要目标。第二季，一旦你把那个掌握了，就是财务。这是你为期四个月的时期，致力于深度学习、学习如何投资、学习如何预算、自我教育。然后第三季可能是，你知道的，它可能是一个特定的
I've suggested this method before if this one isn't the one for you. If goal setting with only one to two things per year is hard, break down your 2026 into three seasons instead. So each four months, each season, you have a separate theme or a separate goal or a separate area that you want to exclusively work towards with concentrated effort. So like season one, what is that? Like January to April, like is fitness. That is the thing, that is your theme. That is your main goal for that season. Season two, once you have that down pat, is finances. This is your four month period to like commit to deep learning, commit to learning how to invest, to learning how to budget, educating yourself. And then season three might be like, you know, it may be a specific
创意项目。所以，如果两到三个目标的想法行不通，将你的一年进行分段以优先处理那些你想要达到的核心事物，可能是一个很好的替代方案。我认为这两种方法都行得通。这只是关于选择哪一种对你的大脑最有效。如果你是一个容易感到无聊的人，在任何特定时间让那两到三个目标持续进行，这样会更有帮助，因为你不会感到无聊，从而放弃。但如果你是一个对事物会变得非常痴迷并进入心流状态的人，我认为选择第二种更可取。你还得学会对那些可能让你非常兴奋的事情说“不”。
creative project. So if the two to three goal idea doesn't work, segmenting your year to prioritize those core things you want to achieve might be a good alternative. I think both methods work. It's just about choosing which one's going to work best for your brain. Like if you, are someone who gets bored easily, having those ongoing two to three goals going at any given time, like it's going to be more helpful because you're not going to feel bored and therefore give up. But if you're someone who can get really obsessive and into a flow state with things, I think choosing the second is preferable. You also have to be okay with saying no to things that may really excite you.
我今年得到了这个机会。我想我还没有分享过，但我得到了一个制作我自己的定制引导手帐的机会。这是一个非常酷的机会。这也是我一直想做的事情。我对此有一个真正的愿景。但我不得不认真权衡：这和我真正想要实现的另外两个目标一样有意义吗？遗憾的是，并不是。
I got this opportunity this year. I don't think I've shared this, but I got this opportunity to make my own custom guided journals. and that's a really cool opportunity. It's also something I've wanted to do for a while. I have a real vision about it. But I had to really decide, is this as meaningful as the other two goals I really want to achieve? And sadly, it wasn't.
所以我对一个我渴望已久的事物说“不”，这很难，但我内心也感到了深深的宽慰，因为我知道那是当下的正确决定。我知道，拒绝这个可能会让人失望。但这并不意味着它以后不会再出现。做更少意味着牺牲，并押注于“这一切都是值得的”这一理念，并且知道你希望能够把它做好，所以给它空间和时间。
So I said no to something that I've really wanted for a long time and that was hard, but I also felt a deep sense of relief in that, like, I knew that that was the right decision for the moment. I knew that, like, turning this down might be disappointing. That doesn't mean that it's not going to come back around. doing less mean sacrifices and betting on the idea that it's worth it and knowing that you want to be able to do it well so give it the space and the time.
今年这一主题的第二个应用，我认为是弄清楚你一天中哪些任务是必要的，哪些事情只是在发出“我很忙”的信号。我不知道你们怎么样，但尤其是当我还在上大学和在公司上班的时候，我花了很多时间做一些实际上毫无用处、纯粹为了做给别人看的事情。其中一件事就是领英（LinkedIn）。现在，对领英或我的领英用户没有任何恶意，但是，我曾经以为那有多么重要，以为那对我的职业生涯有什么重要意义，我花在给老板发项目更新上的时间，比如用一个她根本不需要的、完美策划的PowerPoint演示文稿，
The second application of this theme this year I think is figuring out what tasks in your day are necessary and what things are just signaling busyness. I don't know about you but especially when I was at uni and I was at my corporate job, I spent a lot of time doing things that were just like actually useless and were just for appearances. One such thing is LinkedIn. Now, no hate to LinkedIn or my LinkedIn users, but like the amount that I really thought that mattered and that that was somehow an important thing for my career, the amount that I was like sending my boss project updates in like a perfectly curated PowerPoint presentation that she didn't need.
我觉得那很重要。我花在无休止地重新整理待办事项清单而不是直接去干活上的时间，或者给我的日程表按颜色分类的时间，你知道的，对工作感到自豪并且想要提高效率是很重要的。但如果你想践行我们今年的主题，你必须血淋淋地弄清楚，到底什么才真正列在你的待办事项（to-do）清单上，什么列在“应该做”（should-do）清单上，什么列在“可以做”（could-do）清单上。我过去习惯把所有事情都塞进待办事项清单，就好像每个任务都具有同等重要性一样。但它们其实并不。
like I thought that mattered. The amount of time that I spent like endlessly reorganizing my to-do list instead of just doing it or like color coding my calendar, you know, yes, having pride in your work and wanting to be efficient is important. But if you want to embody our theme for the year, you've got to get bloody clear on what is actually on your to-do list, what is on your should-do list, and what is on your could-do list. I used to put everything on my to-do list as if each task was of equal importance. And they weren't.
这让我很容易拖延，因为我可以去处理那些根本没有任何惩罚关联的任务，或者那些不吓人、不需要深度工作的任务，因为这仍然让我感觉——这感觉就像我正在做点什么。我可以说服自己我正在取得进展。这其实只是一种光鲜亮丽的拖延形式。所以每周，也许每天，你知道的。需要做的事是：写下你今天绝对必须完成的事情。保持最少，保持诚实，你今天应该完成的事情，你知道的，什么会让你的明天更轻松，
And it made procrastinating easy for me because I could tackle the tasks that really had no penalties associated with them or weren't scary or didn't require deep work because they still felt that I was like it felt like I was doing something. And I could convince myself that I was making progress. It was just a form of like glorified procrastination. So every week, maybe every day, what you know. need to do is write down the things you absolutely need to complete today. Keep it minimal, keep it honest, what you should complete today, you know, what would make your life easier tomorrow,
这让我很容易拖延，因为我可以去处理那些实际上没有惩罚、不吓人或不需要深度工作的任务，因为我仍然觉得……这感觉就像我在做点什么。我可以自我说服，觉得自己在取得进展。这只是一种美化了的拖延症。所以每周，也许每天，你需要做的是写下你今天绝对需要完成的事情。保持精简，保持诚实，你今天应该完成什么，你知道的，什么会让你的明天更轻松，
what others may be waiting on you for. And if all else is done and you've got some free time and you want to work, what could you do today? What are some bonus tasks? Because not all those categories are the same thing. Our focus is on working, smarter, not harder, not fatiguing our mind, not fatiguing our cognitive resources with stuff that is not essential or important, especially if it's to give the appearance of productivity. You have to eliminate that. Also, if you're not busy, if your to-do list is done, let yourself not be busy. You don't have to optimize every waking minute of your day. And also, here's a psychological secret for you. Sometimes the best thing you can do to optimize your time is actually not use it and just enjoy it. Just rest. Just switch off.
其他人可能在等你做什么。如果其他事情都做完了，你有一些空闲时间并且想工作，你今天可以做什么？有哪些额外的任务？因为并不是所有的类别都是一回事。我们的重点是更聪明地工作，而不是更辛苦地工作，不让我们的思维疲惫，不让我们的认知资源因非必需或不重要的东西而疲惫，特别是如果这只是为了制造高效率的假象。你必须消除这种现象。此外，如果你不忙，如果你的待办事项清单已经做完了，那就让自己闲着吧。你不需要优化你清醒的每一分钟。而且，这里有一个给你的心理学秘密。有时候，优化时间的最好方法其实是不用它，只是享受它。只是休息。只是关机。
If you take away one study from all of this, I want it to be this one. In a study of healthy volunteers, National Institute of Health Researchers mapped the brain activity that was flowing when we learnt a new skill. And they discovered that taking short breaks from the task, even taking a few days away at a time, was better for learning compared to people who just sat there and kept trying and kept trying to cram new skills into an exhausted brain. There is a restorative science to doing nothing. It's a real tortoise in the hair scenario. Conserving your energy for more important tasks and goals is the best method for success. I'm also committing myself this year to not working on holidays, to not working on my weekend evenings, if I can help it, to not succumbing to the pressure
如果你能从所有这些中吸取一项研究，我希望是这一项。在一项针对健康志愿者的研究中，美国国立卫生研究院的研究人员绘制了我们学习新技能时流动的脑电波活动。他们发现，从任务中进行短暂的休息，甚至花几天时间离开，比那些一直坐在那里、不断尝试、不断试图将新技能塞进疲惫大脑的人更有利于学习。什么都不做有着恢复性的科学原理。这真的是一个龟兔赛跑的情景。为更重要的任务和目标保存精力是成功的最佳方法。我也在今年承诺自己，如果可以的话，不在假期工作，不在周末晚上工作，不向压力屈服
to see rest as simply free extra unplanned time, but plan time. My rest time is, it's planned. There is something scheduled and there's something is to do nothing. Especially if you're a creative person, you know, you'll really understand how important this is in the long run. There's this amazing article from Scientific America titled Why a Rested Mind is a Creative Mind in which the author talks about how all great creatives have one thing in common. And it's not talent, it's not passion, it's time off, sabbaticals, naps, long lunches, weekend, invent. We can invent. I just like woven into the fabric of being a creative person. And I want more of that.
把休息仅仅看作是免费的、额外的、未计划的时间，而是计划好的时间。我的休息时间是，它是计划好的。有安排好的事情，也有什么都不做的事情。特别是如果你是一个有创意的人，你知道的，你从长远来看会真正明白这有多么重要。有一篇来自《科学美国人》的精彩文章，题为《为什么休息的大脑才是富有创造力的大脑》，作者在文中谈到所有伟大的创意工作者都有一个共同点。那不是天赋，不是激情，而是休假、学术假、小睡、漫长的午餐、周末发明。我们可以发明。这就像是融入了身为一个创意工作者的血液中。我想要更多这样的时刻。
The final way I'm applying this philosophy this year, this theme is maybe a bit unconventional, but I'm actually not going to tell people my goals for 2026. I've been kind of mentioning that I have two big ones in this episode. Maybe there's one big goal that I've mentioned maybe offline like in Instagram or something, but I'm not going to be outwardly talking about my goals. And not even with friends. Here is why that's going to link back to my theme for the year. There is this understanding in goal psychology that telling people your goals increases your chances of doing them.
我今年践行这种哲学、这个主题的最后一种方式可能有点非传统，但我其实不打算把2026年的目标告诉别人。我在这集节目里好像提到过我有两个大目标。也许有一个我曾在离线时提到过的大目标，比如在Instagram上或其他地方，但我不会在公开场合谈论我的目标。甚至不跟朋友说。原因将与我今年的主题联系在一起。在目标心理学中有一种理解，那就是告诉别人你的目标会增加你实现这些目标的几率。
It's called public commitment. And to some extent, it works. I think they do it a lot in like AA. It works by leveraging the extrinsic motivational power of embarrassment. Basically, if I don't do this, I'll be embarrassed because people, will think something about me. They'll think something is lacking. They'll think I've failed. And that fear is meant to motivate you. By not telling people, sometimes we assume that means we aren't going to be accountable and we can kind of quit silently. But I read this interesting research the other day
这被称为公开承诺。在某种程度上，它是起作用的。我想他们在戒酒互助会（AA）里经常这样做。它通过利用尴尬的外在动机力量来发挥作用。基本上，如果我不这样做，我会感到尴尬，因为人们会对我有某种看法。他们会认为我有所欠缺。他们会认为我失败了。这种恐惧旨在激励你。通过不告诉别人，有时我们以为这意味着我们不用承担责任，我们可以默默地退出。但我前几天读到一项有趣的研究
that said publicly announcing your goals actually reduces motivation if the announcement creates a premature sense of identity completion before the work has actually happened. you know, doing the thing that you set out to do is obviously the number one option, but saying the thing that you plan to do is number two, because it indicates to people socially like, oh, this is part of my identity. This is like, I'm the kind of person who wants to do this. Whether I do it or not, actually doesn't matter because I've already indicated that it's a desire for me.
该研究指出，如果公开宣布目标在工作实际发生之前就产生了一种过早的身份完成感，实际上会降低动机。你知道，做你着手去做的事情显然是第一选择，但说出你计划去做的事情则是第二选择，因为它向人们在社交层面上表明，哦，这是我身份的一部分。这就像是，我是那种想要做这件事的人。我做不做其实并不重要，因为我已经表明了这是一个愿望。
That says something about me and my character. And for me, what I've noticed is that when I tell people, I don't feel as good about the goal anymore, the expectations, whether people have them or not, it really doesn't matter, kind of strips the intrinsic desire from it all. It also, I've found, kind of artificially speeds up the timeline because you begin to judge your progress by appearances and how it looks outwardly rather than how it's feeling to you as the person who is living within this goal, living the steps, living the work, who can organically see progress. Others might not be able to because you are with the goal all the time you are working.
这说明了我以及我的性格。对我说来，我注意到的是，当我告诉别人之后，我对这个目标的感受就不那么美妙了，人们是否抱有期望其实并不重要，这从某种程度上剥夺了其中的内在渴望。我还发现，它在某种程度上人为地加快了时间线，因为你开始通过表面现象来评判你的进度，看它在表面上看起来如何，而不是去感受作为生活在这个目标中、生活在这些步骤中、生活在工作中、能够有机地看到进展的你自己感觉如何。其他人可能看不到，因为你一直在和目标在一起，你在工作。
So I want to work in silence. And maybe that's the second theme of your year for working in silence, for falling in love with the process before the results, for discovering self-accountability through enjoyment, through passion and personal motivation, rather than relying on others to perhaps socially punish you or make you feel embarrassed in order to do something. So that is our theme for the year. Your year for doing less and achieving more.
所以我想要在沉默中工作。也许这就是你今年的第二个主题：在沉默中工作，在结果出现之前先爱上这个过程，通过享受、热情和个人动力来发现自我问责，而不是依靠别人在社交上惩罚你或让你感到尴尬来迫使你做某事。这就是我们今年的主题。你那少做多得的一年。
I hope the way that I have explained that resonates with you. And it just gives you permission, like just to take a break and just to focus on less. Especially in our 20s, there's so much pressure. I felt it. I feel it all the time. to be like constantly doing a million different things and saying that you're doing a million different things almost like prove that you're using these years wisely. No, like having deep devotion and deep love and deep commitment to just one or two things is so much
我希望我解释这个概念的方式能与你产生共鸣。它只是给了你一种允许，让你去休息，去关注更少的事情。特别是在我们20岁的时候，有太多的压力。我感受到了。我一直都能感受到。去表现得好像一直在做一百万件不同的事情，并宣称你在做一百万件不同的事情，几乎就像是为了证明你正在明智地利用这些年。不，对仅仅一件事或两件事保持深深的奉献、深深的热爱和深深的承诺是如此地
more meaningful. It's like goal monogamy is more meaningful to me this year. So I hope it is the same for you. If you have a different theme for 2026, leave a comment below. I would love to hear it. And I'm so excited for the year to come. I feel like by now you guys will have seen a big announcement. And I, yeah, I feel like I'm going to do a whole other episode talking about it.
更有意义。这就好比目标一夫一妻制对我今年来说更有意义。所以我希望对你来说也是如此。如果你对2026年有不同的主题，请在下面留言。我很想听听看。我非常期待新的一年的到来。我觉得你们现在应该已经看到一个重大公告了。而且，是的，我觉得我要做另一整集节目来聊聊这个。
But I just want to take this second to say, thank you so much. And I'm so grateful. I don't think it's quite hit me yet that that is the next chapter for this podcast. That's unbelievable still. But it's just you guys. Like you guys did that. You've done it all for me. So that I'm just so grateful and I want to say a big thank you.
但我只是想借此机会说，非常感谢你们。我感到非常感激。我觉得我还没完全反应过来，这就是这个播客的下一个篇章。这仍然让人难以置信。但这一切都是因为你们。就像你们做到了这一点。你们为我做了一切。所以我真的非常感激，我想对大家说一声非常感谢。
Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Care Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《用惨痛方式吸取教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Care Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要
listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《用惨痛方式吸取教训》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last time. target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
这就是iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived this. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。1984对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起度过这一切的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈80年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看往昔》。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吗？我对测试动过一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档iHeart播客。保证是由真人制作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。